[Music]
today is national voter registration day
once again nevada seats will be in the
national spotlight in the 2022 election
but there's a growing trend of
nonpartisan registrations reporter kate
houston went to unlv to talk to people
signing up to vote you want your voice
heard everyone really wants that at the
end students at unlv spent the afternoon
registering to vote i feel like voting
is like very important especially if you
want to make a change in today's society
so it's really nice that they're here to
help me get my voice out there the
university sponsored many non-partisan
registration booths we've had a bit of
buzz so we're hoping for about maybe
150 200 folks to register through us
active voting numbers in clark county
show a growing nonpartisan base august
registration numbers show 499 thousand
are democrat 362 thousand are
nonpartisan and 352 000 are republican
republican national committee
spokesperson keith skipper says a large
part of that is due to automatic voter
registration at the dmv we want to make
sure that we are
getting anyone that identifies with the
republican party or maybe doesn't know
what the republican party is to
understand what we're about the limited
government free enterprise liberty for
everyone there was not a
democrat-affiliated registration booth
on the unlv campus in a statement nevada
democratic victory says in part
democrats have and will be focused on
ensuring nevadans are registered to vote
and have access to the voting booth from
today through election day 2022 kate
houston live local now if you didn't
have time to stop by a registration
booth you can still register to vote
online or through the mail the next
election in nevada is the primary next
june